Okay, I want you to follow me on this thought process.
The children would not be around an abusive person
if you weren't in an abusive relationship.
So you're actually not keeping them safe when you're there.
You are the person that brought them into an abusive situation
and is keeping them in that abusive situation.
Because you've tricked yourself to think you're helping
and you're doing good, when the most important thing you could do
is get your children to safety
at least some of the time.
They deserve a break from the bullshit at least some of the time.
But to grow up under someone's fucking hard thumb and rules
and anxiety and tension and eggshells is.
You're not doing what you think you're doing.
You know what I mean? You're the one keeping them in that situation,
never giving them a break from it.
And they could grow up and be like,
well, mom,
if you loved us so much and if you were so concerned,
why didn't you get us out?
Why didn't you give us a break, ever?
Do you know what I mean? I'm not trying to come at you hard.
I'm not trying to come at you rude,
I. You know what I mean?
But you gotta think of it differently.
You're not keeping them safe.
That is their dad. That's the person that is their father.
You can't fucking control that.
You had a chance.
That's the man that you picked to Be the father of their kids.
Believe me, there's lots of us that have to repent for that.
But staying in the situation,
you're not doing them any favors.